von der seite geschützt a a
nein wir waren ein warte bis der hause
bisher reinkommt ich nehme einfach
weiter auf eine hier sind eine stickies
jetzt wächst die kläger war dirk wieder
auf aufnahme gopal ausmachen so so da
bin ich wieder seien herzlich willkommen
zu einem teil des tvp es für luca ist
doppelt gemoppelt aber naja was solls
also sollten wir uns eventuell mal eine
kiste man ja gar kein holz weil ich hab
so unnötige sachen hast du holz hier
fast holz und hier 4
ich habe genug sticks ich habe für dich
auch schon im riffel gemacht okay wie
kriegen wir noch mal munition daher lade
oder die uns gerade jetzt haben wir
schon 64 jeder von uns 32 die manchmal
heraus so und das medi kit ist von eis
so die frage ist was wollen wir noch
machen wollen wir auch eine kneipe habe
ich doch schon die ist ganz wichtig oder
wenn wir von hier bis 12 mal machen wir
uns oben so ein klein aussichtsposten
wir können auf jeden fall irgendwas zum
vielleicht eine shotgun nein dafür
brauchen verdienste oder man schaut gar
nicht schon mal kurz das stück der hält
was ist das denn für ein quatsch das
würde mich mal interessieren wie kann
ich die waffe bobs abschießen abfeuern
kann auch sein
ich setzte mal
was kann ich hier bauen kleine häufig
ist so anvisieren acclaim hier genau das
ist hier allerdings schießt kann man das
ist dieser kasten stelle ich einfach
hier vorne auf einfach mal hier so als
wenn jemand genau hier reingeht
also ich stelle einfach mal hier auf was
für käufer jetzt genau falsch start ist
die claymore meinte genau das heißt wenn
ihm ein tier ist dann explodierte
einfach macht das heute mal stellen doch
lieber hier so hin
hier so und jetzt nicht dass die basic
verletzt naja stimmt das ja verstehen
einfach haben alle seine pace haben die
alle die es gibt
wie konntet ihr alle so eine base machen
hey es kann nicht sein das kann ich alle
sein ist das kann nicht sein dass das
ist nicht rechtens
du könntest noch sonst gern dafür
brauchen wir gar porter scheiße
traveller und apple neben shotgun blog
ein ganz toller mich dass sie warte doch
jan eder kommt raus
das ist die der granatenwerfer brauchen
natürlich mal uns erst mal noch einen
hut bringt jetzt mal den pinsel
naja da kennst du die sachen der fährt
um genommen also haben wir beide noch
nicht weil ich uns jetzt zwei sniper
waffen huston dass mir zugreifen kann
selbst an rewe ich habe gar kein eisen
aber da ist und ich mach kurzer zickzack
zum 15
hier hast du ich kann meinen die kisten
oder hatte ich gibt wieso also zwei
waffen hab ich jetzt da einmal die
sniper einmal anhalt.de was tun bei die
vorläuferin dollar
das heißt es geht los oder offenbar das
heißt wir müssen sehr vorsichtig sein
denn die bands draußen und ich hab noch
ein bisschen über ein bisschen in linx
der munition für dich wie viel hast du
jetzt jemand hat unser claim ausgelöst
da gab es eine explosion ale ein linie
wir sind in der linie des flugplatzes
aufrechtes lukas ein bisschen einfach
warte ich bleib hier vorne stellen ich
stelle mich auf den turm wieder von der
seite geschützt
ar hhg zurück
wir waren ein warte bis der aus bisher
rein kommt war wechselte mit sniper
können nicht theoretischen item auf die
druckplatte werfen
das geht nicht von daher haben wir haben
dividiert und einem schuss getötet und
dürfen die weiß ja nicht abbauen
ok soll ich mal flugplatz gehen oder
warte last zusammen geben auf 3 auf
flugblätter mit hiv oder ich gebe mich
die mithilfe der eine ist oben
ich bin im moment habe ich immer kurz
wieder ein
okay ich bin wieder geheult
das bist du alte scheiße auf fakt ist
aber die macht wann hitze dieser novelle
aber nicht gewinnen die wahl erst mal
kurz wieder rein und frischen apfel
es gibt aber auch ihre freunde wieder
rein jetzt ich bin im arsch wenn die
mich manchmal kommt das geld ja kommen
jetzt die lauf weggekommen zurück in die
mails kaplan barrieren vor besteht nicht
wir sind die größten kakao es gibt da
kommt ob sie können aber nicht schreiben
würden und für welchen bäumen warte ich
habe uns die revolution gemacht hier
ich hab mal 720 und ich habe 26
ich kann es doch jeder machen kann ich
nicht ändern gibt es noch ähnliche
anderen sachen die wir uns machen können
irgendwas besseres cocktail oder
granaten granaten kommen machen eine
granate
jetzt kommt sie jeden moment da kommt
jetzt kommt ihr einen farbstoff den hass
noch farbstoff ding gesteht sein ja rein
schießen darf man abbauen verboten
wir sind in der base lernen die regeln
okay wer dahin geht er stirbt ist auf
jeden fall hast du wie du hast eine
bombe gelegt
ich schieße einfach raus wtf also der 1
ich musste mir also die wahl an die
ganze zeit rein ja die gehen alle nur
von der einige ab sicher wieder durch
noch ist das noch dort ist dass der
macht den namen griff ja ich hab einfach
ab ende kommt die noch nicht raus nein
wird doch hier drin musste raus
warum die besten perfekt taktik
angefangen sie gefangen
luca luka ja ich versuche noch zu
kriegen ich habe nur hätte tja alter
versuchen bauen unsere pace kann
auseinander
das ist es sehr unguten snipers ihr
müsst nicht wahr eingekesselt ich war da
kam die alemannia kam das an email
daraus wirklich muss ja weiter snack
oder c4 platziert
frage ist wurde hier sind
ich glaube so viele leben gar nicht mehr
warten draußen fliegen
rob ist relativ schnell einfach
weggeflogen laufen diese linie gerade
ganz auffällig oft nicht wohin mit der
open beta junge das dauert ja immer
whiskys aufbauen kann ich leben zeig mir
mal hier ich habe kein eis mehr zu
nehmen
johanni haben die kisten nicht leicht
gemacht ich schaue mal kurz wie es ist
ob ich mir nicht so was ist das nur
riffel was ist das eine shotgun aber
jetzt habe ich eine shotgun das ist gut
8 das war nicht so ein erfolgreiches
blätter ich bin noch drin und ich haben
goldenen apfel eis du scheinst du packst
das bestimmt f4 wir glauben an dich alle
aspekte mich ja ich werde welche die
mwst
wieso deportiert wo sind die gegner wo
sind die gegner so ich bin bei dir ich
bin bei dir ich bin da steht er da oben
drauf die combo alltag dass die
screenshot gemacht alles jetzt die show
ganz leicht machen können position
meine waffe in der hand und stellt mal
wieder auf dem rad fährst munition okay
es sehe ich da oben sind comedy fliegen
also über die mauer
wir sind schon raus
also ich hab ne na.de kommt von hinten
der kommt von hinten an deine base sei
jedoch nicht so läuft komplett woanders
hin
wir wollen hier nicht kosten also der
ist ja offensichtlich irgendwo im wald
den packe ich nichts
chemiker sniper juli da hängt mein job
das ist nur ob irgendwo ich würde nicht
so auffällig da stehen da alles noch da
unten
okay okay meine klaus getroffen mit das
leid war ja ich hab den ja auch zwei
oder dreimal getroffen zweiten weiter
entfernung welt läuft wieder weg der
chor war das ganze nur noch ein hartes
los bist du ich glaube wir nur für beide
leben erlebt noch erlebt auch erlebt
doch nicht nur weg zur sicherung sniper
alter ziemlich getroffen
das ist so geil aber unsere pace ist und
so bases richtig nur noch 15 ige scheiße
aber die punkte funktioniert sie läuft
einfach nur die läuft aber bei den
anderen da schauen uns das mal an hier
die anderen beiden körpern also die den
auf jeden fall professionelle aus ich
finde unsere auch schweigsam obgleich
weg alter wirklich wenn er weiter so
provokant herumläuft
als mich in der base und spielt auf
einmal auftreten
wer hat mich die torjägerin xk blabla
bleiben oder palting gerade glaube ich
gut ich muss hier will einer wissen oder
parkbänke tötet nur um etwas ist kann
man bitte durch fragen wer noch lebt ich
habe wirklich angst dingsbums beim
doktor nun spiel mein gott bist du bei
nokia jetzt verfolgt ihr noch erst mal
so ein bisschen und lasse ihn nicht
ankommen ich hab ja alles der spielt ja
nur auf shotgun er spielt nur aus
schottland ich hab ja alles auch die
später von hinten angegriffen
ich habe es nicht gesehen also ich weiß
hinter dir sind spex kraft und luke
place dass die gehen ja gerade auf
nordost du denn da würde ich jetzt ja
okay da würde ich jetzt echt das wird so
glaube ich sterben können wir machen
nachher die aufnahme richtig sind direkt
gestorben
also dann nochmals ich lade das hier
aber trotzdem hoch war witzig und man
heute bei dir rum
ich hab ne ich habe eine shotgun sollen
sich hier nur langsam
geht man den blutdruck stimmt der haut
ab jack ist wahrscheinlich tot läuft ich
schaffe das
ich hab den einfachsten alter die gehe
nicht nur mit shotgun optisch wir müssen
uns gleich auf jeden fall
ich habe mich schon die haben eine ganz
normale die schießen mit diesem mit
diesem dreier dingsbums lieder zeugs da
kommen wir so fünf kugeln raus das ding
ist ich hab nur noch 100 munition alte
dass das problem ist sie gucken ob
irgendwas haben was nicht verbrennen
kann aus einem stück holz und zwei links
scheiße wie soll sich unter bauen weil
er das einer unsichtbaren mauern und die
wahrheit tragen
okay das ist ungünstig dass ihr gott
selber abgebaut habe so alter lieber
folgen nur mich mama fall da man was
machst du dich hintereingang aus und
dann kommt von oben auf die ich
unglaublich alles voll mit schüssen
die laufen weg
doch nun ja dann gehts zum blog des
attentäters nicht allein wirken
diese taktik box
schiester nebenher oder die macht das
schießen damit das leid durch soll
dadurch abbauen der erste der erste puck
der ist ich könnte jetzt natürlich auch
die aufnahme eine frage offen habe ich
mir das einfach viel zu spannend hier
vor allem das ding ist dann einfach soll
mich bauen
ich habe jetzt sind beide dauern
komm schon
nein ich glaube schafft es nicht
ich schwimme
ich denke nein das schafft es nicht die
ganze 23 30 530 schutzalter möglich
aufpassen
wie kann ich kann es mir nicht erlauben
anders zu machen nein ich hab mich sein
freund schildern oder hinten naht der
camper vor allem ich meine camping in
der base finde ich nicht so schlimm also
camping in meiner base
na gut freuen ich will einfach sagen das
was dann erstmal mit der ersten runde
eventuell kommt eine zweite ähnlich wenn
es euch gefallen hatte die band auch
hoch geben nächste runde werden uns dann
wahrscheinlich besser schlagen
man war es das erst mal von mir und kev
alle anderen kenne sind auch in der
beschreibung relativen größe sam hat auf
jeden fall spaß gemacht macht gut und
bis dann